invité de 5 à 10 ce matin hervé tout
c'est le président de la hem pays
l'association martiniquaise pour la
promotion de l'industrie bonjour et
invite tous ses bons jours
en votre qualité de président lundi
comment analysez-vous la crise de la 7e
notamment entre le président de
l'exécutif alfred marie-jeanne le
président de l'assemblée claude lise
vous êtes inquiets mais nous sommes que
je dirais que
nous sommes à quai depuis longtemps
alors que depuis plusieurs semaines
j'interviens pour présenter les
problèmes les difficultés que
rencontrent les entreprises
industrielles
en face on a donc une collectivité qui
se chamaillent depuis plusieurs mois
aujourd'hui c'est donc le président de
l'assemblée claude lise qui est pris à
partie hier cette semaine était un autre
donc bruit oui nous sommes inquiets et
on ne peut pas réagir c'est bien sûr les
affaires politiques nous ne nous en
mêlons pas mais quand on sait que la
plupart des chantiers que nous avons
aujourd'hui en industrie relève de la
ctm et de l'état il ya de quoi donc se
poser des questions vous avez peur que
cela puisse se traduire par un blocage
des institutions de l'institution plutôt
non moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
bloqué depuis longtemps une vue nos
dossiers qui n'avancent pas nous avons
donc la question de l'octroi de mer sur
laquelle nous nous posons des questions
en fin d'année c'est à dire dans une
quinzaine de jours
un rapport doit être remis à l'union
européenne sur l'utilisation donc et le
fonctionnement de l'octroi de mer
on ne sait pas si ce rapport a été
élaboré en tout cas il ne nous a pas été
présentée et nous nous posons des
questions et je pense que oui là la
collectivité est bloqué nous avons des
demandes relatives à leur positionnement
de certains produits dans les listes
proposez donc à d'exonération depuis le
début de l'année l'examen de ce dossier
n'a toujours pas été présentées depuis
près d'un an
en fait vous êtes en train de dire que
vous n'avez pas de partenaire face mais
non on ne les voit pas on ne sait pas
qui s'occupe de nos dossiers
on ne sait pas qui s'occupe de nous
dossier en tout cas ceux qui étaient
censés s'occuper sont prises à partie
par le président donc je m'interroge
vous avez un interlocuteur désigné à la
7e quand on prend la composition on en
avait mais c'était un look tueur là on
ne les voit plus alors dans le quotidien
que vous avez publié
vous avez publié une tribune intitulée
altadis construction de la filière btp
dans laquelle vous pointer un certain
nombre de difficultés vous dit notamment
que les entreprises sont écartés de
marchés publics notamment pose de cahier
des charges
expliquez-nous un peu mais à partir du
moment où vous établissez un cahier des
charges qui exclut des produits qui sont
fabriqués par nos entreprises
industrielles d'emblée vous écartez les
entreprises on se rend compte que sur
des chantiers que nous avons cités
devant le le préfet donc la semaine
dernière c'est c'est les matériaux sont
des pentes et on peut citer donc la
maison de la mère de l'enfant l'hôtel de
police mme michèle cher l'observatoire
du monde des cadets tout c'est tous ces
chantiers là on fait appel à des
matériaux importés du matériel importé
que vous pourriez vous fournir les
matériaux pour reporter que nous
fabriquons nous avons aujourd'hui une
cinquantaine 53 exactement cinquante
trois entreprises qui interviennent dans
le
milieu du btp que ce soit les carrières
les entreprises donc de fins de travail
des métaux les charpentes sont écartés
sont importantes et on fabrique on en
fait plus appel donc au béton qui veut
fabriquer donc dans les carrières on
créé in situ sur les chantiers donc les
l'épaule et produits dont conservant
donc à fabriquer donc à élaborer ces
travaux par conséquent on écope les
entreprises on écarte des transporteurs
qui partent donc des carrières pour
arriver sur les chantiers vous dit autre
chose
vous dénoncez également un réel manque
de respect des normes parasismiques et
par un cycle unique lors de
constructions d'immeubles par exemple 6
ah ben c'est quand même grave si vous
êtes en train de dire l'homme écoutez ce
qui est grave c'est que ça se passe
réellement sur sur les chantiers nous
avons donc des problèmes sur donc de nos
entreprises sont contrôlées
nos entreprises sont contrôlées et nous
sommes amenés à réaliser des travaux de
mise aux normes et on s'aperçoit que 2 3
je des chantiers ne font pas ne respecte
pas ces normes là on a de quoi
interpeller donc l'état et à ses
entreprises en tout cas qui ne
respectent pas les règles doivent être
contrôlées elles aussi comment ça se
fait que des entreprises ne respectent
même ne respectent pas les normes
d'autant plus que on l'a vu au moins
deux pendant la saison cyclonique le
nombre de cyclones de force 5 est en
augmentation donc comment ce que ça a
coûté vous expliquer ça nous allons pas
nous allons pas dans un pays est sujet à
des aléas mais et nous n'allons pas
évoquer donc des difficultés en tout cas
de catastrophe qui pourrait arriver mais
il n'était pas autant donc que nos
politiques et que les services de l'état
et une attention particulière sur
certains chantiers les entreprises
aujourd'hui qui ne se construit sont
écartés dénonce ces phénomènes là il
faudra que on n'a pas une alors on parle
de soi sans faire dans le catastrophisme
vous êtes en train de dire qu'il ya des
nouveaux immeubles ici qui se
construisent et qui sont pas aux normes
alors non je n'ai pas dit que les autres
les immeubles ne sont pas aux normes
les matériaux utilisés notamment quand
vous avez vous quand quand même un bon
thé donc des menuiseries venues de chine
et que c'est nos entreprises sont
amenées à respecter des normes à
utiliser des matériaux qu'ils respectent
des normes donc de dureté et de
fabrication et que vous apportez des
autres des du matin des matériaux venues
de chine
dites moi
si ces matériaux là ont été contrôlés et
comment se fait-il que ces matériaux
arrive sur nos chantiers
vous parlez aussi donc
autre point que vous soulevez les
directement sas et on envie de dire que
c'est récurrent à écouter bon là 13 3
pour les chantiers et et pour d'autres
d'idées d'autres comme andré effectué
par les collectivités on sait que les
collectivités ont des soucis financiers
là dessus on a vu donc d'échantillons
été arrêté parce que les ouvriers
n'étaient pas payés tout petit
revendications la l'or l'an dernier lors
de la grève du bit ip avait déjà été
posée
on pensait que ça avait été réglé rien
n'a été fait et pourtant la 7e avait
injecté plusieurs millions la ctm avait
injecté des millions sur des chantiers
donc à lancer le problème c'est que
c'est que ce chantier soit ils ont tardé
à être lancé soit carrément donc ce que
nous évoquions tout à l'heure les appels
d'offres ont fait intervenir des cahiers
des charges qui exclut et donc des
matériaux donc fabriqués localement et
ce qui fait que ces entreprises là nos
entreprises donc industriels non pas
qu'ils n'ont pas pu participer à ces
appels des conséquences sur les chiffres
d'affaires a bien sûr alors là on est à
moins 40 ans alors qu'il ya eu un
reportage télévisé sur des antennes tv
les entreprises qui ont qui sont
intervenus ont annoncé les chiffres nous
avons réuni toutes ces entreprises
alain pays
il y a qu un jour les chiffres ont été
annoncés entre 2008 et 2016 un chiffre
d'affaires qui a diminué de 1 en moyenne
de 40% les seules entreprises qui n'ont
pas connu de tels chiffres ce sont par
exemple les entreprises de peinture qui
elles sont dans la rénovation et qui
sont amenés à intervenir mais ça ne date
pas de la mise en place de la 7e quand
même ça ne date pas de la mise en place
de sites non nous ne mettons pas en
cause la seteg attention les chantiers
publics ne sont pas réalisés uniquement
à l'est comme les chantiers que je vous
ai cités tout à l'heure c'est pas
uniquement la ctm
il y à des chantiers l'hôtel de police
n'est pas là c'était donc voilà il faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
d'une manière générale sur l'ensemble
donc des travaux réalisés sur le
territoire
il y à une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
record pour ce face à tout cela vous
proposez quoi vous vous une cr c'est une
serre qu'une cellule économique régional
de construction ça veut dire quoi parce
que ce n'est pas en un étage en plus
lorsqu il me semble qu'il y avait déjà
des comités de suivi
il y à il y à un comité de suivi qui
s'appelle donc le là comment dirais-je
la leur au sein de la lamentable il ne
concerne que les marchés publics
il y a à côté de ça il ya pratiquement
autant sinon plus de chantiers privés
sur lesquels il faut qu'il y ait un
observatoire pour le suivi donc des
différents chantiers et une analyse sur
deux pour faire des projections de de
travaux si ce à quoi va servir ce qu'ils
proposent et là c'est absolument avec un
personnel permanent qui qui effectue et
non pas uniquement des réunions avec des
personnes qui peut qui se voient
uniquement deux ou trois fois par annick
girardin la ministre d outre mer sera en
visite en martinique que vous pouvez
vous attendre de cette visite exactement
alors annick girardin
vient certainement pour suivre les
travaux qui ont été lancées notamment
sur les assises des poutres mais le trou
mère est là dessus nos entreprises donc
se réunissent régulièrement dans tous
les ateliers dans tous les ateliers ils
se trouvent tous ces problèmes seront
remontés un à un en gironde alors les
problèmes nous avons fait le diagnostic
on va pas revenir dessus nous avons fait
le lien le diagnostic
aujourd'hui nous proposons des projets
et donc des projets qui pour lesquelles
nous demandons à l'état un financement
est en vie tous et je vous remercie
excellente juridiction notre antenne
merci
[Musique]